Wow it's like two Olympic movies in two
weeks love our Olympics as for sure so
any of the Eagles the story of Eddie as
a kid he always had hopes and dreams of
being an Olympic athlete he didn't know
what sport at first it was Summer
Olympics in Winter Olympics and skiing
in ski jumping
against all odds he's like I'm going to
be an Olympic ski jumper never done it
in my life but I'm gonna start now after
that is pretty much Cool Runnings with
one guy doing an Olympic ski jumper I'm
not just saying that this is a pretty
formulaic movie about the human spirit
and it's not about whether you win or
lose about how hard you try you got to
get back on the horse he's being taught
by a coach who was really good at that
sport back in the day and he had a fall
from grace so this is some form of
redemption for him this story even takes
place at the same Olympic event as Cool
Runnings the same year there's actually
a cool Easter egg where someone mentions
that you're making bobsled team and one
saying I thought that was pretty cool
it's a pretty by-the-numbers movie this
movie panders - we human beings being
drawn to a story of one person's
hopeless optimism he just wants to do
his best yeah this may be the second
Olympic movie in two weeks but this is
not the story of Jesse Owens Jesse Owens
was a gifted athlete who brought home
four gold medals enemy Eagle has the
heart but you really do feel for this
dude somehow we all get it in our heads
at a point in life or like you can't
actually pick up new stuff because I'm
just too old - that's not true you can
never stop doing you can never stop
learning pick up new things that's an
important thing it's an important
element of life this way we celebrates
that and most formulaic way possible I
thought Hugh Jackman was really good as
his drunk coach I thought Taryn Edgerton
was fine as the lead Eddie the Eagle in
this movie so we're a little weird that
they got him to play him nothing I don't
like because I think that kids a good
actor he has a bright future ahead of
him I'm just saying he doesn't really
look like the actual Eddie he is dumb
it's really funny this wave of movies
where it's not whether or not you win
and lose its whether or not you try
because you can pick a lot of people on
earth and they have a similar situation
there weren't cameras rolling when it
happened so who's to say they don't
deserve a movie made about their lives I
don't know I'm gonna keep this one short
because that's what the movie is this
movie skates by by pandering to your
wanton need to hope and root for
underdog the performances were fine the
premise is interesting in the end it's
great seeing this dude get back on the
horse after Stonewall after Stonewall
after Stonewall and keep trying I locked
out of Eddie the Eagle with a smile on
my face and I will say Eddie the Eagle
is a good time no alcohol required I
grew up on these movies Cool Runnings
iron will I enjoy it
all right so Eddie the Eagle have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite underdog story of
all time whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to say more
[Music]